quand ero un adolescente criticavo mio
padre lo criticavo per tante cose come
fanno spesso gli adolescenti ma una
delle cose per cui lo criticavo era che
lui non buttava via mai niente
anche un oggetto vecchio rotto usurato
scheggiato per lui aveva un valore se
non in quel momento in un momento
successivo quando lui poi lo avesse
aggiustato cosa che non succedeva mai e
quindi noi ci trovavamo la casa sommersa
di piccoli e grandi oggetti e rotti beh
la cosa più pazzesca è che dopo averlo
criticato tanto io mi ritrovo a fare in
età adulta esattamente come fa lui non
riesco a buttare via niente
beh forse è per questo che la mia
attenzione è caduta su un articolo che
parlava del kin sughi il kin su vi è un
arte è un arte giapponese allora
letteralmente riparare con loro da keane
oro e fuggi riparare è un'arte che
utilizza una lacca speciale con dentro
delle polveri d'oro per riparare degli
oggetti che vengono rotti utilizzando
poi il prezioso metallo per coprirne i
punti di giunzione
questa tecnica permette di ottenere
degli oggetti preziosi sia dal punto di
vista economico per via della presenza
dell'oro sia dal punto di vista
artistico perché ogni oggetto diventa
unico e irripetibile per via della
casualità con cui la ceramica si rompe e
quindi per via delle variegate e
ramificate decorazioni che si formano
sull'oggetto e che vengono poi
evidenziate dall oro beh io voglio
aggiungere che secondo me la preziosità
dell'oggetto aumenta soprattutto per il
valore del tempo della dell'attenzione
della cura con che si è messi per
aggiustare questo oggetto
pensate che in giappone esiste proprio
la figura del maestro di keane sughi e
un oggetto riparato
un rinomato maestro arriva a valere e
costare parecchio perché perché si
creano delle vere e proprie opere d'arte
sempre diverse ognuna con la propria
trama da raccontare
ognuna con la propria bellezza da
esibire proprio proprio in virtù della
propria rottura di come si è di come si
è frantumata beh noi oggi che cosa
facciamo
quando un oggetto si rompe ha perso la
sua integrità
lo buttiamo non lo ripariamo ne
compriamo uno nuovo è il e il consumismo
facciamo così anche con le relazioni
ormai ma guardate come può essere bello
invece un oggetto riparato con lì con i
suoi punti di rottura evidenziati e non
nascosti
noi sì aggiustiamo qualcosa lo facciamo
prendendo una colla trasparente stando
bene attenti a non far vedere i punti di
giunzione non si deve vedere che
l'oggetto sia rotto beh comunque prima
cosa è che il kin su chi mi da ragione
non bisogna buttare via niente
che poi ci ritroviamo con qualche cosa
di più prezioso ma soprattutto mi aveva
colpito mi aveva colpito tanto da
salvarne una cartella sul desktop e
andare a prendere maggiori informazioni
il kin sughi nasce in giappone nel
periodo muromachi sotto lo shogunato di
yoshimasa nella seconda metà del
quattrocento e questa è questo è un
periodo molto fertile sotto il profilo
culturale e molte sono le arti che
vengono importate soprattutto dalla cina
in giappone arti come il teatro no
l'arte della cerimonia del tè l'arte di
comporre i fiori recisi l'ikebana tutte
facenti parte di una corrente culturale
che si basa sul buddismo zen questa
corrente culturale si chiama wabi sabi
wabi sabi racconta della semplicità
della natura dell'accettazione
dell'imperfezione del difetto
senza nasconderli e dell'accettazione
del passare del tempo che porta a una
serenità interiore
la leggenda racconta che fu proprio
yoshimasa che ruppe la sua tazza da per
la cerimonia del tè preferita e volle a
tutti i costi che fosse aggiustata
provarono primi mare maestri ceramisti
cinesi ma il risultato non venne bene
poi provarono i maestri ceramisti
giapponesi e appunto inventarono questa
questa latta particolare che diventa
molto forte una volta asciutta e insomma
il risultato piacque tantissimo io
cimasa e quindi il kin subì prese piede
in giappone cosa succede quindi in
giappone se una tazza una vecchia tazza
si rompe non si butta si ripara dandole
una nuova vita rendendola ancora più
bella e preziosa rendendolo una vera e
propria opera d'arte che proprio in
virtù della propria rottura ha una
storia da raccontare e noi
quando siamo noi a romperci quando
andiamo in mille pezzi e pensiamo che
non riusciremo mai a mettere insieme i
cocci
quando succede qualcosa che ci rompe nel
corpo e nell'anima
usiamo dire ho il cuore a pezzi e
succede che perdiamo perdiamo la
speranza nella vita nel futuro
perdiamo la fiducia in noi stessi
l'intero è rotto i pezzi sono parsi la
vita che c'era prima
non ci sta la frattura sembra
irrimediabile
[Musica]
a
che fatica ma che risultati è stato
proprio in un momento doloroso della mia
vita che sono andata a riaprire quella
cartella sul desktop e l'ho guardata in
modo più approfondito la filosofia
giapponese va oltre la riparazione di un
oggetto il che in sughi suggerisce
paralleli suggestivi non bisogna buttare
ciò che si rompe la rottura di un
qualche cosa non ne genera più la fine
e i suoi punti di rottura diventano
trame preziose
bisogna cercare di recuperare e non
mollare
questa è l'essenza della resilienza in
occidente la sofferenza è considerato un
sentimento sterile e non un moto
dell'anima attraverso il quale ciascuno
di noi può arrivare a comprendere meglio
se stesso reinventarsi ridisegnando la
propria esistenza
la vita è integrità e rottura insieme ed
è ricomposizione costante ed eterna
ciascuno di noi deve cercare di far
fronte positivamente ad eventi
traumatici e crescere attraverso le
proprie esperienze dolorose
valorizzandole ed evidenziando re e
convincersi che proprio grazie a queste
che siamo diventati delle persone uniche
è proprio grazie agli ostacoli che
abbiamo superato i traumi che abbiamo
subito e le sofferenze che abbiamo
sperimentato che siamo diventati più
preziosi e più ricchi la caduta la
frattura ti stanno dando una visione
della vita che se fossi rimasto intatto
non avresti avuto sta a noi scegliere di
dipingere le nostre difficoltà con loro
il dolore elaborato passa e ci lascia
cambiati a volte più forti a volte più
saggi
ma in ogni caso lascia un segno e
l'elaborazione di una ferita è un
procedimento lungo che necessita
pazienza e amore
mah che garantisce dei risultati
imprevisti e bellissimi e può rivelare
aspetti nascosti e forme nuove
affascinanti e i punti di rottura sono
ancora più forti perché le linee di
frattura riempite con loro hanno messo
in luce una parte di te che prima non
conoscevi non siamo mai rotti senza
possibilità di aggiustarci state
scegliere di rialzarti ed imparare da
quello che è successo e diventare una
persona migliore
e poi scegliere di indossare le tue
cicatrici come fossero medaglie come a
dire guarda quello che ho attraversato
perché è quello che mi ha reso la
persona che sono adesso e ora possa
attraversare qualsiasi sfida la vita mi
presenti ogni livello della tua vita
richiede un nuovo te ea volte abbiamo
bisogno di romperci per raggiungere
quella nuova versione di noi
grazie
[Applauso]